foreign
[Music]
here are the seven dragons that have
been seen as of now in the house of the
Dragon series and there are three other
new dragons that will be seen later in
the first season so let's get to the
ones already seen name them all and then
come to the most probable ones that will
be featured later on let's get to it
number one Cyrax the very first dragon
to be seen was the one that belonged to
princess renera Targaryen and this is
Cyrax the golden scaled Beast that was
still a young dragon when the initial
episodes happen which was set in the
year 104 AC but by the time of the later
episodes she would have grown bigger
since 15 years would have passed since
the last we saw of her in Dragonstone
she has two blunt straight horns on her
head and greenish eyes
number two galaxies the second dragon
that was seen was none other than the
blood worm this Dragon looks the most
different from all the others it was a
deformed dragon that had a serpentine
body and a secondary set of wings on its
hind legs the tail also seems to be
fogged and its head based to Carnotaurus
inspired horns and this Dragon was way
bigger than Cyrax but not as massive as
others of the same length and age
number three sea smoke the Third Dragon
to be seen belongs to sir lenov valerion
and this one was a bit smaller than
karaxi's but bigger than Cyrax seismo
was a white and Ash colored dragon with
a bulky and robust upper torso and a set
of massive wings that had pinkish tin
coloring on its wing membranes the head
of sea smoke spots two curvy horns and a
face that is very similar to the dragons
of Daenerys Targaryen
number four melees the next is the Red
Queen and she is a magnificent Beast
that belongs to princess Venus she was
seen flying alongside sea smoke in the
fifth episode melees does appear to have
been one of the oldest and largest
dragons after Vega herself and was
probably one of the second generation
dragons hatched to The Originals melees
has a similar body shape to Sea smoke
but was red in color and spots a crown
of large horns on her head and neck
number five Vermax in the latest episode
there were three other new dragons seen
the first of these was a very small
Dragon called Vermax this dragon is in
the process of fully bonding with Prince
jakaris Targaryen or Valerian Vermax is
green in color with the yellow golden
scales and looks very similar to the
third season dragons of Game of Thrones
most notably rhaegal Vermax although a
small Dragon was still capable of
breathing fire hot enough to Rose a
sheep in seconds
number six dream fire just a few minutes
after Vermax prints aemon Targaryen
comes across another dragon that made
its home in the dragon pit this Dragon
looked very similar to Sea smoke and
could have very well been him but for
the slight difference in coloring with
this one being darker with the bluish
Tins in its scales dream fire was the
only other dragon that was pale blue
with silver gray features and it could
be her but it could also not be her so
let's put this one on the debate section
number seven Vega the next dragon to be
seen in the sixth episode isn't up to
debate this massive Beast is the biggest
dragon at that time she is Vega and is
one of the original dragons of aegon
Targaryen and the only one that is still
surviving Vega is massive around twice
the length of karaxi's therefore putting
her around 200 feet or 60 meters long
and visibly very old and Asian she is
pale yellow in color and the only one
without horns on her head her wings are
huge with reddish tins and can cover
entire villages in her shadow
number eight so now we come to the
dragons that are highly probable to be
seen in the first season and the first
one we are guessing to be is Sunfire
this Dragon bonds with Prince aegon
Sunfire will be another dragon that is
of yellow golden coloration but with
pinkish Wing membranes uh he is still a
small Dragon during this time and will
be the most beautiful dragon scene in
the series and that is why he will be
the next dragon to appear in the
upcoming episodes most probably because
he was already mentioned to have been
bonded with Prince aegon in the series
number nine air acts in the sixth
episode it was hinted at amongst jakaris
lucerius valerion aegon and Emma
Targaryen the only one left without a
dragon was aemon
hence it's safe to say that Luke or
lucerius valerion had already bought it
with a dragon erax and this Dragon would
have still been a small and fledgling
male dragon Iraq's would later grow big
enough for the prince to fly on top of
him but sadly this Dragon would not last
long enough in the dance of the dragons
and number 10 Moon Dancer in the same
episode it was stated by Elena valarion
that her daughter Bella already had a
dragon so it's safe to assume that the
Targaryen girl had bonded with the
dragon Moon Dancer which would have
still been a very young dragon during
that time but big enough to fly and
fight during the dance of the Dragons
although way smaller she would have been
faster than a crippled Sunfire with both
dragons meeting their end due to their
battle later in the show oops spoiler
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video on the dragons of season 1. do hit
that like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel
till the next one take care fam